this new whole jewel box collection you
put out
i particularly love when you go to your
demos
is the demo just sort of a sketch if you
compare it to painting
yeah it's exactly that it's a sketch
you're exposing yourself in a way is
there any trepidation in doing that
i had a lot of trepidation because i
thought oh they're going to sound awful
they're going to sound terrible
and what they do sound is naive and
sweet
and it's like i describe on the it's
like
it's like an embryo the the demos of the
ember of our relationship with
songwriters
and then we made those demos and then we
recorded an album called empty sky and
then
we were born and then we made elton john
and we started to walk
and then we made tumma weed and we ran
and then we flew
and so it's the hatching of an egg and
and so it's like baby steps learning to
walk and
some of them are very twee and some of
them but they are what they are they are
the story
of how we evolved our songwriting
relationship
there's a version of coming down in time
that's got out on 10 inch
single that was recorded obviously at
the same time as the original
that i don't remember recording it so
the same kind of
just a piano bass and drums um on a
guitar
and at the end of it i just go into like
a six minute jazz solo or
whatever and i love it but i don't
remember recording it um on a lot of
these things i don't remember
so it was great to go back and and
really appreciate where we came from
how hard we worked the disappointments
that we faced when we wrote some of
these songs and nobody wanted to hear
them and nobody wanted us to do anything
with them i don't regret any of it
whatsoever
because it it's the journey you can't
tell the journey
in in truth and unless you bear your
soul and these were our
little souls being buried when we were
18 or 19 years of age